so
can you tell us a little bit about how
you started to make art
everyday
and before that james houston arrived in
cape dorset um
what kind of art did inuit people make
and do you remember the first time you
met james houston um and his wife and
and what did you think of them the first
time that you met them
um
and
your work appeared in the very first
cape dorset print collection
in 1959
and
what do you remember about that time
uh
what are your favorite things
you're so famous for
um especially um your drawings of owls
birds moons
what do you think it is that that makes
your images so appealing to to
collectors and to galleries not just in
north america and canada but around the
world
after all these years i mean you have an
extraordinary 50-year career behind you
was art a way for you to make money for
your family
or
does art give you something personally
and spiritually as well
what do you think about um
sort of the younger emerging artists now
and some of the the mid-career artists
um some of them are still doing what
many people consider like the
traditional inuit art um wildlife uh the
scenery around cape dorset some are
doing uh
work more about uh social issues in the
community
and the more modern aspects of cape
dorset what do you think about about
these new images and this new group of
emerging
foreign
and how do you think uh environmental
changes might be reflected in the art
that the artists here produce
foreign
how do you think the
we celebrated the 50th anniversary of
the cave dorset print collection uh last
year
um
what do you think the cape dorset print
collection will be over the next 50
years
how do you think it's going to change
and how do you think it's going to stay
the same
when it's the day of the the cape dorset
print collection the day that it's
released your images are the ones that
are bought first it's the ones that are
are sold out first and people call you
the greatest producer of inuit art i'm
curious is that how you see yourself
when people talk about you as a
producing inuit art
do you see yourself as someone that
produces inuit art or do you see
yourself as a as a canadian artist who
just happens to live and work in the
northwest
you